c'est là à palmiste rouge dans cette
vallée encaissée à quelques kilomètres
de la ville de cilaos que lucienne et
eve a ouvert voici quelques années la
seule ferme auberge du quartier le cadre
enchanteur dans lequel elle nous emmène
aujourd'hui la saveur des plats et
produits de la ferme qu'elle laisse
deviner sont autant d'atouts que la
profession qu'elle représente cultive
pour conserver l'authenticité du coeur
de notre île pourquoi le bonheur parce
qu'il ya une montagne juste là peu près
à 20 minutes d'ici qui s'appelle le
bonnet du prêtre et puis comme ce1 senti
assez fréquentes et je veux dire par
beaucoup de réunionnais le missouri
sudoku l'idée m'est venue comme ça
voilà
pour tenir votre ferme auberge ce qu'il
fallait investir dans du matériel
sophistiqué que c'est vrai il ya aussi
cette différence avec les tables d'hôtes
justement parce qu'au niveau des tables
d'hôtes huile essentielle de leur
cuisine familiale et paix nous il faut
avoir puisé normes européennes je veux
dire avec du matériel en inox enfin
c'est vraiment
une cuisine comme dans la commune
restauration car ça nous
créé par la tap que meringuée où il est
là il ya un barbare au coco si vous
c'est très demandé mais c'est assez
varié aussi comme dessert donc là vous
pouvez trouver donc la tante commun
qu'est la taute papaye l'atteinte à la
banane qu'est ce qui est encore le
gâteau patate de gâteaux chouchou est ce
que le fondant au chocolat enfin je fais
un peu de tout quoi
vous faudrait montrer aussi avant je
faisais la broderie et oui mais comme
j'aime bouger donc la penderie faut
rester sur place donc c'est pas vraiment
un donc je faisais quand les enfants
étaient petits justement il fallait
s'occuper d'eux pour passer le temps
donc c'était la broderie
je lis que je n'aimais pas vraiment
faire ce à quoi
bon journées sont organisées comment
quand vous avez un gros gros
donc en général et groupe c'est plus le
samedi et le dimanche donc s'est réservé
beaucoup à l'avancé on travaille de nuit
parce que comme je fais la crise et le
principe si on est tout seul donc à mon
mari qui je vais dire qu'ils tuent les
canards et les poules et mais après pour
la préparation donc de cuir comme on dit
a à z c'est moi parce que c'est mon
domaine je ne veux pas que tu as hâte
d'être
donc là il faut travailler de nuit et
puis mes mais c'est comme je vous disais
que le week-end donc après le lundi donc
on ferme on a le temps de se reposer on
peut commencer après voilà voilà
à la ferme auberge à ce qu'on vient
publiquement peut manger dormir et
restait plus à jour en général dans les
fermes auberges la plupart ou des
chambres donc on peut aussi dormir à
couillet et puis quand les gens viennent
c'est plus un jour il ya surtout eu ici
c'est plus pour le cadre le calme et
puis ça change un petit stress de la
ville
les gens qu'est-ce qui viennent
découvrir s'élancera pas liste rouge en
particulier c'est vraiment la vie à
l'intérieur de lier le la vie des
cultivateurs en général et puis comme le
disait à chaque fois eux mêmes dans les
restaurants ils vont il ya de bons
restaurants mais la convivialité c'est
pas la même chose et puis s'ils veulent
vraiment découvrir la vie des gens et de
lille c'est la meilleure façon
et puis les balades ils vont envahir les
bana dossier pc de magie si c'est pas
connu il ya de belles petites balades
quand même est-ce que vous regrettez
vous ce que je regrette c'est que je
devais quand les gens honnêtes sur
cilaos en général c'est si la hausse
parce que l'égalité am la broderie de
cilaos le vin de cilaos donc tout est
centré sur cilaos en général mais si on
regarde bien les lentilles de cilaos eux
ça vient des écarts par exemple de deals
et accorde de panis de rouge de la prod
année c'est la même chose il ya 80% des
points de vue qui se fait à pas mr rouge
d'accord mais tout est centré sociale
donc c'est ce dommage que les quartiers
ne sont pas ceux connus à côté quoi que
les gens y viennent de mon corps en
général comme l'a
souvent j'ai remarqué qu'ils demandent
toujours les lentilles cilaos est ce
parce qu'on verse il apprécie revoilà le
cv car c'est très demandé où le cari
poulet pays c'est surtout les
traditionelles pour vous avez un champ
de lentilles voilà on a le chien anti on
trouve un peu de tout
trouve justement qu'ils se font attaquer
pas mal parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas
toujours à reconnaître des lentilles de
cilaos et le land sea d'ailleurs alors
est ce qu'il ya une astuce comment
reconnaître de l'entité là c'est
possible de reconnaître mais il faut
vraiment être habitué parce qu'on trouve
des lentilles je veux dire sur le marché
qui ressemble à peu près aux lentilles
de cilaos donc c'est pas évident mais
les lentilles de cilaos eux à sa couleur
au général on la reconnaît et puis elles
sont très fines d'accord - dont claude
maintenant plus facile on est habitués
on peut reconnaître les notes in house
et vanessa chef n'est pas vous c'est
vrai c'est pas évident c'est aux
alentours de combien de kilos eu une
moyenne de 60 francs 50 60 francs le
kilo à trouver le pré justifier les
personnes qui achètent trop sa chair en
général mais si vous avez un kilo de
lentilles vous pouvez manger je vais
dire à 25 personnes
dans un kilo de lentilles et puis pour
les personnes qui cultivent c'est vrai
que nous ça nous rapporte pas quoi en
difficulté justement à cultiver les
lentilles donc la plantation parce que
ces faits tout manuellement après donc
il ya la récolte aussi là s'est arraché
les faire sécher battre au fléau enlever
les pailles crible et enfin c'est tout
un travail
donc c'est chiant c'est vrai pour les
personnes qui achètent mais pour le
planteur de ses parents durable voilà et
vous commencez à les planter à quel
moment de l'année peut donc on commence
à planter vers le mois de
mai avril mais la cueillette - c'est le
mois de septembre octobre en général
dont vous avez des lentilles c'est chez
vous de l'année oui et donc une fois
récolté donc ça se conserve je vais déjà
séché donc sans problème y retourner
l'année passée pour consommer sais pas
comment on peut aussi un surplus ça
dépend justement de leur école parce que
maintenant avec les vers blancs et c'est
vrai que c'est pas évident cia jusqu'à
ici donc
des fois on vend le sûr que je vais dire
sur place mais on garde la consommation
pour la femme engagée toute l'année
votre mari travaille alors que oui donc
il est dans le champ des rentes il
enlève les nouvelles scènes
je sais qu'il faut arroser
sa demande très peu d'eau pas beaucoup
oui oui mais c'est une contrainte parce
que même si on essaie le désherbant par
exemple ça marche pas il ya toujours des
mauvaises herbes qui poussent donc ça ne
vaut pas la peine on est obligé
d'enlever laisser-aller faut constamment
voilà des mois que pendant quatre mois
c'est
que s'occuper des lentilles de la
plantation comment tu as commencé à
gratter l'ancien
lui ont toujours besoin de plus le plan
un accord oui
parce que vos enfants ont envie de
refaire ce que vous faites l'aîné enfin
ma première fille oui justement elle
enfin elle à rêves des projets peut-être
à long terme justement et puis faire
quelque chose je veux dire sur le
terrain
parce que je veux dire comme il ya déjà
la ferme auberge avoir une activité à
côté vedettes de s'attirer attirer les
touristes et les gens aussi donc il ya
des projets mais on verra
plus tard 6 à 6 à dire ou pas quoi
et quels sont les avantages de ce métier
on a le contact avec les gens tout le
temps donc on a l'impression de voyager
sans voyager et puis ça nous donne envie
de découvrir autre chose et puis comme
je dirais on est son propre patron on a
personne pour nous dicter ce qu'on a
fait avant que c'est très important quoi
est-ce que l'on peut vivre de ce métier
correctement
je dirais oui
parce qu'on peut trouver chez nous du
vin c'est là où se trouve aussi en
petites quantités mais y'en a aussi
fabriqué maison fabriquer les ont tout à
fait maison est d'accord oui
vous occuper des vendanges c'est donc là
c'est aussi le travail de mon mari ou
non n'a pas beaucoup mais donc ça se
passe en général deux mois de janvier
février mais le vin fait de manière
traditionnelle
et puis c'est l'ancien variété isabelle
justement qui en voie de disparition ça
c'est là où est ce parce qu'il ya
d'autres avec des nouveaux de nouveau
chai de cilaos il ya d'autres variétés
qui pointent deux places et puis là
c'est un bon vin de table apparemment
fait partie quelle est cette association
lesquels votre rôle dans cette
association donc comme les fermes ou
bien je sais à la rhino je vous dis en
association qui s'appelle l'association
bienvenue à la ferme donc au niveau
national dans toutes les régions il ya
justement une association qui fort qui
regroupe tous les fermes auberges et
donc on se retrouve une fois par mois un
profil rhino de travail pourra car s'il
ya toujours 20 des fois on fait des
voyages justement et à l'extérieur de
l'ailé tout donc on met tout en place et
puis voilà et puis je suis aussi
trésorier de cette association parce que
ça vous prend beaucoup de votre temps
c'est une journée par mois je veux dire
repos les réunions de travail donc sur
370 georges aboké et puis il faut
prendre le temps et ça nous permet de
nous rencontrer aussi et puis de sortir
un petit peu de temps en temps vous
occuper de votre ferme auberge 11 est
trésorier dans une association et que
vous avez le temps de faire autre chose
comme monte il faut toujours prendre le
temps un filon si on regarde son travail
on n'a pas le temps donc je prends un
temps je veux dire tous les sens comme
j'aime bien faire la course à pied le
son je veux dire entre 5h30 et 6h
ennemis là où tu m'as tellement je vais
aller courir sauf le week-end c'est
impossible mais au moins quatre fois par
semaine je vais essayer de faire ça des
fois quand je ne sais rien des périodes
de creusot c'est donc là je profite pour
faire des grandes randonnées tout cas
lorsque j'aime bien ça et puis vous êtes
inscrit un groupe pour marcher avec de
la salade du tonneau en tout cas ma
fille donc des fois le pacte c'est pas
des cross de montagne d'être comme ça
donc encore ensemble je veux dire des
fois comme elle s'entraîne donc je
l'accompagné en même temps et voir mais
moi c'est pour le plaisir
des foires sont justement parce que
c'est bien de travailler mais comme on
dit un proverbe qui dit justement il
faut travailler pour vivre mais nous
vivre pour travailler dont il faut
justement essayer de voir les choses de
cette manière et que de prendre un peu
de temps pour soi pas c'est votre devise
voilà est battu